good morning as chair of the house ways
and means committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive audit 20 2004
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a revenue work session please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600
or email hcs lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that's on
the meeting assisting us
christopher shea and jennifer four
please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance
when each member states that president
please also state whether there is
anyone in the world when you join this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
representative bernstein could you take
the membership or the raise and means
committee thank you
good morning mr chair and thank you
today is march 31st
2021 it is 9 03 a.m and i'd like to
extend a warm ways and means welcome
to our guests emily brock thank you for
joining us today
and senator daniels thank you let's
begin roll call with
representative patrick abrami you're
here in my home in stratham and
my wife is in the house representative
mary griffin
representative jordan owery holmen
hudson the wife is in the household
representative ohman hudson with
six cats incidentally yesterday
one of the cats was outdoors so during
roll call there were only five
now there are two i thought something
smelled fishy there yesterday
i'm glad they're all counted for it
representative doucette
red ducette your clerk is alan burstein
i'm in my home office in beautiful
nottingham new hampshire
representative robert elliott here in
salem new hampshire
home of the first lottery and my wife is
in the living room
good morning representative john
genningen
yes i'm here in my home office in salem
and my wife is somewhere in the house
good morning representative nunez good
morning mr clerk i am home alone at my
home in pelham
representative baxter good morning mr
clerk i'm home alone but there's a very
large and loud turkey surrounding my
house so if you hear any noises from the
turkey
representative walter spillsbury good
morning home alone in charlestown
good morning representative tudor homer
northwood wife and grand
kids are upstairs morning representative
army
alone in lebanon representative ames
i'm here in jeffrey alone in my office
representative southworth here alone in
dover
representative malloy here alone in
greenland
representative thomas schomburg
representative chambers is in
london on this truck by himself good
morning representative edith tucker
i'm home alone in randolph
representative jenny gomarlo
representative is in swansea by herself
but my husband somewhere representative
tom laughman
representative representative amanda
gorg
good morning i am present and alone
representative mary hacken phillips
good morning i am present from uh
hanover alone
representative james murphy
representative murphy
representative chairman norman major
good morning i'm in my home office in
plasto my wife is in the house
good morning mr chair there are twenty
members present four members are
unaccounted for
thank you representative murphy was uh
said he would be late
thank you representative
[Music]
as you all know we have the
president has signed the latest stimulus
package 1.9 billion dollars
and there'll be money coming to the
state
to the counties to the towns and the
cities
and we're all wondering
what can we do with the money and what
are the rules and regulations
and so that we can
utilize the money the way it's supposed
to be
we're fortunate that we have mis brock
from the government finance office
association
she is the director emily leads the
coalition in advocacy efforts
of the public finance network in
washington dc
her advocacy includes anticipating
and responding to federal legislative
and regulatory
activities that impact the finance
functions of state and local governments
and public sectors entities
including tax reform municipal security
disclosure
and public pension and benefit issues
emily also serves on the staff of gfoa's
depth committee
to develop the best practices that
promote sound financial practices for
local state
and provincial governments prior to
joining
gfoa emily was a commercial bank
relationship manager at a large national
bank serving
as the sole bank liaison for government
and university clients
so mrs emily brock
hopefully you're going to provide us
lots and lots of valuable information
so it's all yours i certainly strive to
mr chairman thank you so much for having
me here today
um and thanks for the opportunity to
chat about
um the american rescue plan act of 2021
i'm
i'm going to refer to it from here on
out as arpa
as its acronym arpa kind of sounds like
i'm barking a little bit but no wildlife
around my house just yet um so i will be
referring um
to that quite a bit and also i will be
sharing slides with you
you've had um miss floor was um nice
enough to distribute these slides to you
i'm certainly happy to provide any more
um
information around uh arpa that might be
helpful for you beyond
of course this um this time with us
uh today time we have together today so
i'm going to share my screen
before you start joining us is senator
bob geider
who's chairman of the senate ways and
means committee
lovely thank you so much for joining um
so
let me um as i'm sharing my screen i'm
going to put it on
presenter mode um now i i wanted to to
launch
into arca but i also wanted to lay a
little bit of groundwork
um for getting us to where we are today
as we know
uh president biden and vice president
harris's
um uh uh our american rescue plan
um came on the tales of some other
stimulus legislation that happened
during the trump administration
and so some of your cities and towns may
actually have
uh some derivative effects from
previously enacted legislation that i
thought maybe it'd be good to talk about
just for a quick moment
and this is um specifically i'm i'm
going to move beyond the cares act the
cares act passed congress last year on
march 23rd was enacted on march 23rd and
there was coronavirus relief funds that
were distributed as
um the paris act was passed of course
now there are there is an extension on
the coronavirus relief funds that kind
of leads us
into today but also at the end of last
year
there was an omnibus plan that passed
and it's called the coronavirus response
and relief supplemental appropriations
act and if
if you recall that actually is an
extension of
the omnibus so it was the budget that
had to pass last year
um uh in in washington but in addition
there was a 900
uh billion dollar stimulus uh plan that
was attached to that
and some of those things um are actually
relevant for your cities counties and
towns
you know but also the state of new
hampshire so um
in the in in the in the plan that passed
at the end of last year the chronovirus
relief fund
funds were were extended so basically
you can spend those crf
funds beyond december 31st 2021
another thing that's really important
for your cities um and your counties
is an extension and a re-up of what we
call the emergency rental assistance
program so
25 billion dollars for
cities and counties of above a certain
threshold in population
will receive 25 billion dollars for
emergency rental assistance
um in addition there was education
stabilization and as we all
know um an extension of unemployment
insurance
another thing that's probably less well
known that
um that a lot of my membership is is
asking about right now
is there was a a low income utility
assistance program that was in
that act as well 638 million dollars
that's kind of sitting right now with
the
um department of health and human
services or hhs
um and they're still crafting a plan
about what are the what
what are the parameters there how do
low-income qualified
uh recipients apply for that but the
most important thing to your cities
counties and towns is that that utility
assistance
could go directly to your um
your water programs um or others
so so that's an important part of kind
of what we're dealing
now right now with the emergency with
with arpa is that there's still some
legacy or derivative effects of the
previous
two um the previous two stimulus plans
that passed in the trump administration
and so we're still kind of massaging
that information out for our membership
so they know
where that money is coming from and
where
it possibly can go um
so let's jump right into it the american
rescue plan
of 2021 passed on march 11 2021 it was
signed by
uh president biden um what happens in
um in in federal legislative efforts
is that um there's there's a timing or a
clock that's set
in legislation that says post enactment
then uh there's a clock that starts for
distribution of those funds so
in the american rescue plan act 2021
signed on march 11
they have 60 days post-enact
post-enactment to distribute those funds
um and and the act itself is very very
large we all know that
um it's nearly two trillion dollars
a very important critical feature i
think of it
is that it was able to pass with
relative ease but it
very narrow margins so um it was only
the democrats in the senate that voted
for the bill but nevertheless they used
a
budget tool called reconciliation that
allowed for them to pass that bill at a
very narrow margin
and um it was quickly funded and here we
are so we're waiting right now
during the 60 days post enactment period
to understand what the distribution of
the funds look like
um of that 1.9 trillion dollars
uh 350 billion dollars is dedicated to
states
and local governments as you all know
the state
portion of the funding is 195 billion
dollars
and in the act there is a minimum
threshold distributed equally among the
50 states so the 50 states get
at least 500 million dollars and the
district of columbia gets 1.25 billion
now the remaining amount will be
distributed according to a formula that
takes into account each shares state
each
each state's share of the national
figure of
unemployed individuals now probably were
aware
um in early march there was a fair
amount of conversations between
governors
and the administration to say why are we
distributing it according to unemployed
individuals as opposed to population
um and most of those states uh were
states that had
um had local and regional economies that
could withstand the pandemic so they
were saying it's not
fair we we would prefer for it to be um
according to population but nevertheless
the way that the
final bill was wrote written out um
it is actually based on unemployed
individuals
uh compared to the national share of
unemployed individuals um now the
one of the most important things about
um
making sure that the money gets to where
it needs to be
is that the bill has written into it um
a certification
process um so for states
for example um each state
has to certify like for example new
hampshire has to certify
to the united states treasury that they
will be using that 1.9 billion dollars
that they've been allocated
same thing goes for
communities for cities and counties each
one of those jurisdictions
has to certify with the united states
treasury
that they will be using those funds
that's an important part because
there currently are a lot of gfoa
members i can tell you that
who are asking me when can we certify
how do we certify where do we where do
we send the letter
um everybody's ready to certify for
their funding
but yet um there really hasn't been
anything yet
determining um exactly what
communities are going to be getting um
this is a
really very interesting part of a sort
of sort of a speed bump along the way
and the speed bump is of course that you
can't certify
if you don't know what you can spend the
money on
so but there's a lot of heart carts and
there's a lot of horses
so we're trying to make sure that we
situate it so that communities
understand um what they can spend the
money on
another element of section 602
of 9901 so this is the state
distribution section
that i thought was very interesting is
that in the bill
uh the uh congress passed they give the
secretary of the treasury so secretary
yellen
the authority to split payments to state
um she has the authority to distribute
the first 50
in the first year and if she so decides
she can
split that in half and create it another
payment 50 percent
of of the state's allocation a year
later
um though reading it and of course
talking with the united states treasury
and talking with the white house
we don't get the sense that secretary
ellen intends to do that for the state
um we think that that was written into
the bill simply to mirror
um local distribution the way that the
local distribution acts
um but we don't think that secretary
ellen will split those payments but
nevertheless i think paul should be
aware
that the legislative text gives
secretary yellen permission to split
those payments
12 months apart um
one of the really important things about
this is that
about the legislation itself is that
there is a specific clause for
recruitment of proceeds um just like in
the coronavirus relief fund in this one
they say
should you spend the money outside of
the eligible expenditures articulated in
the bill
then the united states treasury has the
authority to recoup those funds so
another really important critical
feature
it's not that the treasury is kind of
releasing those funds and not auditing
there will be a specific and a measured
approach to auditing those funds how
states are spending them
how local governments are spending them
and that's an important feature of the
legislative text
i want to move on to section 603 so this
section 603
is an articulation of how cities and
counties will be getting
their money um so obviously as you know
states are going to certify for that 195
billion dollars
they will get a distribution of the
proceeds no later than
60 days post-enactment now the
derivative
of the 350 billion dollars the part that
not
that is not going to the states is 130
billion dollars 130.4
and it's it's distributed equally
between cities and counties so
cities will get 65 billion dollars
and counties will get 65 billion dollars
i'm gonna go to counties first the
distribution to the county source
because it's actually
easier the way that they've written uh
counties into the bill is that all
counties
across the united states will receive 65
billion dollars
and the distribution of it is based on
the community development block formula
for counties and if they are
not entitlements counties that is they
are not cdbg
recipients they will
receive a distribution based on the
population
and in the in the legislative text
congress was really careful to say
you know what um if you do have a cdbg
formula you fall in a cdbg formula but
yet we look at your population and your
population
puts you at a larger amount than your cd
share your pro rate of share is greater
than your cdb share
will grow with we'll go with the greater
of the two
and so that's a relatively easy um
figure because if you look at the
counties across the country i think
there are 84
000 counties across the country or i'm
sorry 8 400 counties
across the country um and so the
distribution is relatively easy
cities get a little bit more complicated
because
there are cities uh there are
substantial amount of cities that are
not cdbg recipients
and so what congress has done is they
said
um the larger of the counties so we're
taking that 65 billion dollars and for
the larger of the cities those that have
a population
over 50 000 they'll receive
45.5 billion according to their cdbg
allocation so a very easy number that
they can pluck from
housing and urban development or hud
they can just
pull out that cdbg formula and use that
formula to distribute that 45.5 billion
dollars
it's a little bit more complicated when
we talk about
towns in smaller cities whose population
is
underneath that 50 000 threshold i have
to be very
clear here though um 50
000 in population is not necessarily a
bright line
for cdbg recipients a town can be
45 000 in population and still be a cbbg
recipient
so if that city or town
is a cdbg recipient they will be in that
first formula
they'll get 45.5 billion dollars
if they are not then they will receive
a distribution uh based on their
population share
and i would imagine in new hampshire
there's probably a fair amount of
jurisdictions that fall in that category
one of the most important elements of
this middle
bullet point the smaller jurisdictions i
think for you
in particular is that those monies
will flow through the state in the
legislative text
they said that money that is reserved
for those smaller jurisdictions
will flow through the state the state
will get the allocation
for the smaller jurisdictions and then
the state will be responsible
for distribution of those funds to the
smaller jurisdictions
they also put another restriction on it
they say
state you must take that money and
distribute it to the
smaller jurisdictions but in addition
qualifier is that you can't give more
than 75 of their most recent budget
and that's baffled a fair amount of
states i've got to be honest with you
i'm talking with you know obviously
virginia wisconsin uh nebraska
texas a lot of the states across the
country
don't necessarily collect their local
communities budget
and so in order to ensure that the
distribution does not
exceed 75 of the smaller community's
most recent budget
that will require some homework some
extra work on behalf of the states to
ensure that
the distribution to those smaller
communities does not exceed 75 percent
of their most recent budget
and and another important thing of
course is that
um there is a time parameter based on
this
so in the legislative text obviously
you have so march 11 the president
signed the bill
he has 60 days to distribute the funds
but because states are responsible for
distributing the money to those smaller
jurisdictions
there's actually another claw that's
built into the legislation so
60 days post enactment and then inside
the legislative text they say for states
that have to redistribute to smaller
jurisdictions
you have another 30 days to make that
happen
they're giving you another 30 days so
technically 90 days
post march 11th then
additionally in the legislative text
they've given you the opportunity
to appeal for more time
so you have two different periods of
time where you can appeal for another 30
days
in order to get those funds out and the
appeal
basically is the state the state
executive uh calling
calling the treasury saying we need
another 60 days and here's why we need
another
we need another 30 days and another 30
days we need another 60 days
distributes funds and it's very likely
what i anticipate from other states
certainly
it's very likely that they will be
trying to make ensure
that they comply with the legislative um
text um condition
that the distribution cannot exceed 75
of their most recent budget again
so that's just a really important
qualifier for states
um one one thing that my members have
brought up to me of course
is um with the single audit act
uh the smaller communities are wondering
if in fact they are sub-recipients of
the state and therefore have to comply
with the state requirements as opposed
to the local requirements so we're
we're talking with treasury about that
right now
for section 603 uh which is again the
distribution to the localities
the legislative text is very specific
payments to local
governments will absolutely be made in
two tranches so
unlike the state where they've said
secretary
ellen has the option of sending out the
money into
tranches in the local government section
they're very clear to say that payments
to local governments
will be made in two tranches by the
united states treasury
the first half those localities will get
60 days after enactment
and the second half will come exactly
one year later so if let's say they
um aren't able to distribute the funds
by may 11th
uh local governments will receive their
first tranche on may 11
2021 and their second tranche on may 11
2022. so important sort of qualifying
factors of when the money goes out the
timing
um and the parameters on those monies um
is definitely articulated in the
legislative text
now what's a little bit more ambiguous
and i'm going to sit on the slide for
just a minute
is how uh jurisdictions can spend the
money
and as i understand this conversation
today is to try to take to the bottom
of that um so so let me let me first
talk about each one of the eligible uses
and eligible use a looks very familiar
to coronavirus relief fund recipients
so in the cares act the crf funds they
were
very um very specific about the fact
that you could only use the money
to respond to public health emergency
with respect to covet 19. so the current
awareness relief fund or the crf funds
were subject to that restriction
but in this legislation they take that
restriction
and then they expand on it substantially
um one thing that they do in eligible
use a and i
i i'll point it out to you in line two
of the first bullet
they add on three words for its negative
economic impacts so that is something
that's totally different than the cares
act
negative economic impacts could be
interpreted many different ways but
a lot of your finance officers who are
my members um
you know obviously if this is a federal
grant we want to make sure that we're
using the money according to the
to legislative intent so what we need
is a better definition of the negative
economic
impacts of the public health emergency
for example some of my jurisdictions
have called and said well what if we had
deferred maintenance
during covid19 and we need to
patch up roadways is that a negative
economic
impact of the public health emergency um
we do not have any more definition on
what negative economic impacts means but
if you look at the rest of the eligible
use a
they give you an idea maybe you're
thinking about
uh assistance to small businesses that
was certainly something that the
coronavirus relief fund was being used
for
what about assistance to non-profit or
impacted industries in areas that depend
on tourism and hospitality revenues
so they give you an idea in the rest of
that eligible you say
that that that possibly some negative
economic impacts could be that but it's
not
limited to that so a very important
element of lgbt
in eligible use b this is entirely new
something totally different from
the coronavirus relief fund what an
eligible usb
is saying is that states and local
governments
can use the arpa funds to respond to
workers
performing essential work during the 19
emergency
and the states and local governments can
provide them premium pay
to eligible workers
what's a great thing about this clause
is that there's a lot of definitions of
each one of these words
inside of the legislative text so we
have a little bit more understanding and
eligible usb
of what qualifies so first of all they
define the word
premium pay they say
you can provide up to thirteen dollars
per hour
additional pay uh to these employees not
to exceed
twenty five thousand dollars in the in
the calendar year
then they also define eligible workers
they say eligible workers are an
employee
of the state or local government
who are deemed essential by the
executive
so essentially if we're talking about
new hampshire it would be
the executive of the state determines
who is an eligible worker
and who is not an eligible worker i've
talked to several communities across the
country
that their executives let's say it's a
county administrator executive
who are saying well all of my employees
performed essential work
and all of them are eligible workers
nowhere in the legislative text is that
limiting
so you kind of think about that if an
executive determines that
all of his or her employees are
essential
that is absolutely allowed in this in
the legislative text given the
parameters
so again that's thirteen dollars per
hour not to exceed twenty five thousand
or an eligible worker that's determined
by the executive
four eligible you see now this is a
little bit more complicated
um a little bit more complicated to
measure at this point because we don't
have a whole lot of definition
in in eligible uc so what eligible you
see is getting at
before we start in the in the words what
it's getting at is it's saying
a lot of communities across the country
have lost revenue
due to the pandemic now for communities
that could mean
for lots of communities across the
country it could mean sales taxes it
could mean property taxes and it could
mean income taxes obviously new
hampshire is unique
florida is unique in that there's no
income tax so there's you know some
communities have one of
two of three of those some of them have
all three
and many of them have have had to dip
into reserves
in order to provide the vaccine or in
order to
provide for coronavirus uh the
coronavirus pandemic to their
communities
and so what congress is telling us about
eligible you see
is that they're saying you can claim
that loss of revenue
and use it for the provision of
government services
so let's say the town of emily has lost
10 percent of her sales tax revenue
um what i can do according to eligible
uc
is i can look at the loss that i
incurred
back in 2020 and i can account for that
even though i booked the loss back in
i can claim that as an eligible use in
2021.
so if i had say an 8 reduction in my
sales tax revenue collection
i could theoretically take eight percent
of that
those expected revenues and use that as
an eligible use
now it gets complicated let's say
you have a community who owns and
operates a municipal zoo
obviously you haven't had revenue from
that municipal zoo operations in quite
some time
because there hasn't been a community
going there paying revenues to get in so
there's
there's been there's been an actual loss
in an enterprise
in your community and that's the zoo the
question for eligible uc
is can i book that loss from the zoo
and then recoup those funds and put them
back into my general fund
in eligible uc there's no there doesn't
appear to be any restrictions
on the fact that you've lost revenue in
one category and you can take that
eligible use and put it in another
category of the government
so there's a lot of conversation right
now for communities saying
can i take a book loss on my port
or on my zoo or on an other um
enterprise of the government and then
use that money to replenish my rainy day
funds
so that's certainly a question for the
treasury that we're hoping to get more
clarity on
in the future certainly within 60 days
the last eligible use category is very
explicit
it's very it's almost painfully explicit
um what they say is you can use this
money an eligible use of arpa is that
you can make
necessary investments in water sewer or
broadband infrastructure
for a lot of communities across the
country they're saying well that's kind
of limiting
what if i have school repairs or hvac
systems that i need to
to do what if there are parks and
recreation facilities that need upkeep
what if there's
other capital projects that i need to
invest in is is eligible use d
limiting my possibilities of using this
money for
capital improvements or capital plans
so i mean i think for most of us as
we're looking at the eligible use
category d we're saying well that's a
good suggestion but
where else can capital projects fit
in these eligible uses could i
conceivably
use the loss of revenue in eligible use
c and spend that on say a fire station
so i booked a loss of the zoo it happens
to be the exact amount of money that i
need for a police station
could i use that and then therefore i
have those capital projects that i can
take up
that i can use this money on that will
help me to
both receive rescue and look forward to
recovery
um so but really quickly let me touch on
so those those are what you can spend
the money on
they're also very explicit about two
things that you cannot
spend the money on can not
uh in the state section 602 you
cannot be used to directly or indirectly
offset
tax reductions or delay a tax
increase which is very
complicating for a lot of states and
their plans for this money
as you can imagine if you're looking at
all of those eligible use categories
they're easier in some cases for local
governments to implement for example
premium pay easier for local governments
to implement
um the elevate the public health
emergency and boots on the ground that's
those are easier to implement for local
governments
so you look at the restrictions and you
say yourself okay well
states actually you know there's a lot
of things that states are trying to do
to keep up with the tax credits that
were built into the current legislation
but also yeah you know that's what
states are
they they are they they collect the
taxes they spend the taxes this is this
is how
states operate and so when that
restriction was put in at the last
minute
there's a lot of states that kind of
seized up and said okay
um now i need a little bit more clarity
on what i can spend the money on
and so um a lot of state governors
called secretary ellen and said what
exactly do you mean by that restriction
and what secretary ellen said what she
said was
you know funds are fungible i think i
think there's a lot of people who've
been using that term over the past two
weeks funds are fungible
and what she means is you can kind of
take that money
and put it elsewhere in the government
where you have general fund revenue that
then would allow you to
directly or indirectly offset tax
reductions or delay taxes so
um she's kind of saying don't take that
pot of money and put it directly
into tax reduction put it elsewhere in
the government so that the government
then using fund accounting can figure
out
sort of those big chess pieces and allow
for the state to
efficiently use their 195 billion dollar
distribution the other restriction that
was very clear and was in there from the
very beginning
both in the house bill and the senate
bill was that funds cannot be deposited
into any pension fund and again um
that it's very explicit that's that
that's exactly in the ledge text
funds cannot be deposited into any
pension funds so in theory
um it would be that you can't take the
1.9
trillion or a billion dollars you can't
take that and just put it directly over
into the pension fund
but a lot of your local governments are
looking at that restriction and saying
well
what if i wanted to cover payroll does
that mean that i have to explicitly
separate
compensation from benefits and
specifically for those who are earning
pension benefits
do i have to explicitly separate the two
so we're asking treasury again for
clarification on that
and the last restriction on the funds is
that
funding has to be um available through
and must be spent by the end of calendar
year 2024 so the clock is ticking
starting now through the end of 2024 to
spend those funds
um recently we got a call from the white
house and the treasury
and they said um they said do your
members have any questions about the way
that this money can be spent
and we said yes lots and we have lots of
questions
and what they did is they sent us sort
of categorically what they wanted to
know they were saying
um okay so do your people have any
questions about
the eligible use categories do you know
what they want to spend it on already
and what have you learned
from the coronavirus relief fund
and so a couple of a couple of big
categories of course
fall within that permissible use
category we want to make sure
that when you're looking at revenue
replacement that you can look
retroactively
or if you're talking about premium pay
that you can look retroactively
one of the greatest challenges with the
ledge text the literal
interpretation of the ledge text is
there's not very good interpretations of
the covered period
are we looking backwards are we looking
forward if we are talking about revenue
replacement are we talking about revenue
replacement
in 2023 if so what am i comparing that
to
so a lot of questions for the treasury
about can you help us define what the
covered periods are
so we know how we can certify these
funds
the other thing that we mentioned to
treasury and and the white house as we
were talking to them
is that the qualifications of the
restrictions on the use of revenue
we really wanted for states to better
understand
what that meant directly or indirectly
offset
the tax increases um
the the last thing i wanted to mention
when talking with the treasury
um we made it clear that there's a lot
of urgency
in our membership a lot of folks are
ready to certify those proceeds
but we don't have an idea about how they
can certify the proceeds or what the
eligible expenditures are
and so we asked treasury is there any
way to speed up
or get us more information about
specifically maybe maybe
examples of what the eligible uses
are give us a couple examples so we can
start building out those certifications
and what they told us and i think it's
important to share with you is that they
think that
getting out the guidance might take the
full 60 days
that they're not ready to put out the
guidance yet on
um the arp of funds so we have to be
patient in some ways
but also understand as we're talking
with treasury and as you all are talking
with treasury and as there's
conversations happening
that i think treasury is learning that
there's a lot of learning that has
occurred since the use of the
coronavirus relief funds
and we do we do have a treasury that's
listening to our concern so i think that
that's a really good sign here that we
can teach them
what's happening how what our concerns
are and that how they can clarify those
eligibility to proceed
better giveaway
uh came together my membership came
together
and said there's a lot of ambiguity in
these funds and there's a lot of
there's a lot of plans already being
made
um so your finance directors your budget
officers your tax assessors and
collectors
um who are my members came together and
said can we set up some principles
some core principles for the finance
officers having conversations with their
elected officials
and these are things that you probably
have already thought about yourself and
your committees
um certainly something that's being
articulated every day in city and
town and county councils but the fact is
um these arpa funds are temporary
they have to be spent by 2024.
and so there are some communities across
the country i think what we're trying to
do is sort of
balance the logic of the fact that there
are some communities that were
significantly harder
hit by the pandemic who had to dip into
reserves
and so ensuring that those communities
understand
replenishment of reserves should be a
high priority and the reason for that is
so that they can
rebuild that they can recover that they
can
be rescued from the pandemic so a
a clear guidance from gfoa saying
make sure that you prioritize that
replenishment of reserves
on the other hand if you have money left
over
or if you didn't have to dip into
reserves and you are thinking about
either critical infrastructure or
in a creation of new programs we offered
a couple sort of cautionary statements
they said if you're
if you're thinking about critical
infrastructure consider that you may
already have a list
you may have a capital improvement plan
or a structural budget that
allows for investment in critical
infrastructure this would be a unique
opportunity for you to be able to do
that
to use those funds on that um
last but not least a cautionary
cautionary statement to those who are
thinking about
programs or add-ons to programs is that
if they do require an ongoing financial
commitment that's something that should
be documented because you need to be
able to
sustain that program through 2024. if
you use the grant funds to create a new
program
consider that those are going to have to
be ongoing concerns
throughout and beyond that 2024 time
frame
another thing we wanted to make sure
that local jurisdictions
and i think this is especially important
for you all as you're thinking about the
relationship between the state and the
local governments
we wanted to get to the local government
level and say listen
local governments states are going to
have a lot of initiatives
based on their their receipt of these
arpa funds
so make sure there is that communication
between the local government and the
state government
so everybody understands how those funds
are being used
but it's not just state local
governments that are receiving
arpa rescue funds there are
pk 12 there's economic development
there's transportation money going out
there and so we told the local
governments you know
as you're considering and you're talking
with your county councils and your town
councils
consider that there may be other
recipients in your community
and if you can partner or maybe even
create cooperative spending programs
then you can augment the rescue on
behalf of the community so
another consideration for local
governments moving forward
and then last but not least one thing we
wanted to make sure
that gfoa members understood and i i
think they have a very
strong understanding of this um is is
sort of the concept of patience and time
um yes the funds have to be spent by
but also consider you have until 2024
and the local governments as
as you all you can see local governments
are particularly um sort of staged
because they have that two
tranche distribution they only get half
the first year and they
only get half the second year so there's
a natural governor
built in to the local spending programs
so it allows for the finance director to
say
hang on a second should we solicit
you know um information back from our
communities
should we take a second to look at what
the first tranche did
and then reassess how we can utilize
that second tranche
before 2024 so that timing element was
something that our membership thought
was really important for
local finance officers to have that
conversation with their
uh with their decision-making bodies
um those of course are are sort of key
things those aren't the only things
um one of the other major things of
course that communities are thinking
about
is um capital infrastructure and
physical infrastructure and investment
and um we just wanted four communities
to better understand that structural
integrity of what you're about to spend
it on
is a structural integrity that will lead
to recovery so
again just trying to make sure that the
gfoa members
and that communities across the country
understand what this should be used for
and how it should be used
um that's the conclusion of my written
statement or my
rather the powerpoint slides as i have
it but i'm certainly happy to take
questions
well thank you that was excellent
it raises a lot of questions
but it also gives us more understanding
of what's happening
so questions from the committee
or the joining senators
first is representative
thank you mr chair i've got a couple of
questions on that um
previously um uh what do you call it
critical workers
had been defined by the secretary of
treasury does
the previous definition of who was a uh
worker go by the boards and there's now
a new one being developed by the new
secretary of treasury
so the definition of essential workers
is
now given to the executive of the entity
so
the local government executive or the
state government executive or tribal or
territorial uh or territory executive
you make the definition about who is
performing the essential work
and determine those eligible workers
that's a definition that was included in
the legislative text
well to follow up on that miss brock
go ahead thank you mr uh mr chair um
previously uh banking institutions uh
um financial operations were considered
essential workers
i don't think that a local um executive
uh
understands the breadth and width of
that uh
definition are are banks no longer
essential under this
that's correct so essential workers are
defined as
workers of the state local government
territory or tribal government so
um it would not extend so if for example
if a
community is working with a contractor
for example that's outside of the
employment of the jurisdiction and so
therefore
can't be determined to be um that that
ele
ineligible for being the essential
worker having that definition
okay uh follow up again mr chair
i would like to get as many participants
asking questions
one more okay um
this would be for example uh county
nursing homes uh
here we have county nursing homes which
are operated by the
county governments which the budget is
set up by
the representatives uh in the county
who are seated in the county and the
commissioners of the county so could
this money be used for example
to pay for air filtering systems that
were installed
and extra staff and paying for sick
leave
and such like so in terms of the
employment
of the individuals at the nursing
facility it does
it what really matters is how those
nursing facilities are incorporated if
they
if they are a governmental entity then
fall underneath the governmental entity
classification
um and so therefore fall underneath the
um
the executive's definition um so that
executive then would make the
determination whether it's of the county
or of the state
if they are performing essential work um
but
with regard to i think your second
question which is let's say we need to
revamp these um infrastructure
facilities
um is that an eligible expenditure
listed
in um the eligible use categories a
through d
so no nursing facilities are not
explicitly
um identified in subcategories it
through d
however on the other hand if there was
revenue loss or if there was specific
expenditures occurred as a result of the
pandemic
then those categories fall underneath
eligible use category a
those covid 19 expenditures do fall
within that eligible use category a so
that was what i would lean heavily on
if you're considering infrastructure
upkeep for
things that um that that
that were down that were run down as a
negative economic impact of covet 19. so
i think that falls clearly within
eligible use category a thank you it's
very timely emily how much time do you
have
so um i i have 30 more minutes
okay thank you um next is
going to be tactic of romney followed by
representative almy
senator ryder and representative elliot
one question and one follow-up
representative bromley
thank you mr chair uh thank you miss
brook uh nice presentation
so my understanding is that uh treasury
secretary yellen hasn't finalized her
rules at the same time the 60-day clock
is ticking
i'm having trouble reconciling those uh
how do how does how do town cities the
state
counties do that there are a lot of
um plans being plans being made
without uh official guidance out from
the treasury yet and what towns
and cities and counties and states are
are doing is they're
interpreting the the literal
interpretation of the legislative texts
so they're starting to write plans based
on the literal interpretation of the
text
of course i think the most important
point of our our
of our considerations piece for gfoa and
our membership is
to take a little bit of time
one of the biggest challenges
represented is that
um you know the 60-day clock is ticking
and what we fear
is that the certification and the
eligible uses
come out at day 58 and then you have to
scramble in two days to make a
certification
get a plan together and receive that
money on
day 60. um so that's why the urgency has
been communicated to treasury uh
secretary yellen
um and of course i'd urge that um that
folks uh
provide her office as much as as much
information as she can in order to
help create that guidance swiftly
because our communities need that
oh just a quick follow-up mr chair
any any chance to realize that uh
they're boxing
everybody in and that to to add to the
60 days
i think there is a lot of concern
for both of the recipients of arpa and
also for those folks inside treasury
pulling that information together i
think that there is um
significant outreach and they're
certainly trying to make sure that they
work as quickly as they can to get that
guidance out
okay thank you representative
thank you mr chairman on two things
just a quick follow-up on that one is
there any effort to get the congress to
pass something really quickly that would
add another
month or two uh to that
so um
yeah you know asking congress to like
act within 60 days this
might be asking for an impossible feat
but um
we we have been talking with uh senate
finance um
and with the ways and news committee
about the urgency here and we've been of
course sharing our information with
congress so they understand
the national league of cities the
national association council state
governments
we're all kind of talking with congress
to make sure that they understand
there's great urgency here and that
anything that we can do to help speed up
the process
is much appreciated yeah and and
as part of that could you just tell me
when does this 60-day clock ring
so it started on march 11 and the 60
days will be done on may 11th
thank you and if if i could have
my follow-up on is
ineligible uses it only refers
to state territory or tribal government
are you saying that somewhere else there
isn't a definition that says
that that also includes towns and
counties
and cities so that's a great question
i feel like maybe you've read the text
so in
section 602 that is the section
so subtitle m section 9 to 901
um their section 602 specifically refers
to how states can spend their money
section 603 is specifically how local
governments
spend their money the restriction to
directly or indirectly offset tax
increases
only shows up in section 602
it does not show up in section 603
so you do have a lot of local
governments looking at that saying well
the restriction is only for the states
it's not
in the local government section um so
that that that
i think is a curiosity um and we
certainly need some clarity from the
treasury on that
if i could just get clarity sections b
and
c only mention state territory or tribal
government
but that does elsewhere in the text
include the counties county center
that's correct
that's correct yes yep
senator geiger
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
presentation
uh miss brock two quick questions uh
will there be a document that provides a
a layout of the review
of the timelines for distribution and
the appeal process for local communities
yes i think treasury was very specific
when they were created the cares act
fund the coronavirus relief fund
of what money was owed to what entities
and then additionally the sequences of
audit that were required
based on the receipt of those money so
um
what we learned from the coronavirus
relief fund is that
the sequences of audit have to allow
for states and local governments get the
information together
electronically submit the information
and for the treasury to process that
information
so um what we've asked is for timing and
specific dates on when that audit will
occur
obviously the recruitment of funds will
after the close so december 31st
2024 they're going to make a
determination that
all of those funds were used for
eligible use categories
and then that's when the recruitment of
funds clock will start ticking
okay thank you uh the second question if
i may mr chair
yes uh your slides will be will be able
to
download a copy of your slide
presentation yes
um i i absolutely i believe the staff of
this committee
can distribute that to you mr chairman
all right thank you very much
we've distributed that but we'll redis
distribute it again okay representative
elliott thank you mr chair
madame brock i want to thank you for
your exhaustive
report you did a wonderful job
and my question was the same as the
senators uh
where will we be able to get copies of
this plan
off of our computers you're sending
something out
okay thank you mr chairman i want to
remind the
members that this has been recorded
and so you'll be able to uh
i'm going to show it to my county
commissioners
and to my local offices
and selectmen and that because it's
important to all of them
and we thank you mrs brock
okay next is representative ames
okay thank you and first i just want to
echo the
appreciation for your comprehensive
report
very helpful
new hampshire is in the process of
working through
a budget um a budget for the next two
years we call it the biennium
and um that's a comprehensive budget
that uh
that has spanning items that depend on
spending sources that are state revenue
as well as federal revenue
and and so
what we're going to get federally of
course matters
to the decision i'm aware of
i've read that vermont has factored into
their budget they're working on it too
they're a little ahead of us i think
um an anticipated receipt of
our money and um
i guess the appropriations related to
that would be conditional
on you know the money coming through and
on the guidance that we're all waiting
for and so forth
um and it seems like a smart thing to do
when we're talking about
an estimated maybe 960 million dollars
that's the number i've heard for
new hampshire um it's a lot of money
we're a small state
and uh so my question is uh
whether other states are doing
as i think vermont is doing um
what are sort of the limitations on
doing something like that
um you know that we could just leave it
all to the executive
some feeling the legislature needs to be
involved and that's how the
appropriation process works
so there's definitely a
a desire i think i think probably all
legislators on this call
share in it to set up a process
that includes the full
all branches of government in making
these decisions not just the chief
executive officer so maybe you could
speak to that
um thank you for the question
representative so um
some states um have uh processes
that are inclusive of all
branches um some states
do largely set
um appropriations conversations are in
and around the executive and then the
legislative
the legislative body kind of concurs
um one of the biggest challenges i would
say
about these funds and to i think to your
point here
is that um should are we accounting for
these funds
and um
with a with a decent understanding of
how much we're going to get
um so i think it's important to ensure
that the secretary
of the treasury yellen um that she gives
us
an understanding of exactly how much is
going to the states
so that the decision making that happens
based on the biennium budget which is
happening right now in many states
almost all states and in counties where
we
don't know so secretary ellen has been
afforded the opportunity to split the
money between two years i don't think
she's going to do that
but that's written into the legislative
text so that's maybe one thing that um
that the executive and legislatures need
to consider
is the fact that maybe half of it will
come now and half of it will come later
i think until we better understand
exactly how that distribution is going
to occur
um it's it's very important to be as
inclusive
in the decision making as you possibly
can because of the
abundance of opportunities that may be
provided by the loose interpretations of
the eligible use category so
um i think again you have a significant
amount of work ahead of you
and not a whole lot of clarity um so the
more clarity that comes along of course
we'll be pushing it out to our
membership and
and i know csg will be pushing it out to
you all um but
just to be sure it's important to not
set the cart before the horse
thank you i'm going to sneak a question
in
on the small jurisdictions where
they say the funds should not exceed
75 percent of their most recent budget
you know
like in new hampshire the towns
when they handle their budget and have
to raise its
local taxes it deals with
the municipal part the school part and
the county part
does this indicate it's just the
municipal part
at 75 or the total budget for that
community
it says exactly what the ledge text says
in the bullet point so it says 75 of
their budget which
as you can imagine mr chairman has
created a lot of confusion
across the country because are we
talking about the general government
or maybe just the general fund of the
government
or are we more inclusive like you said
if you have a pk-12 system
and you have other enterprises that
you're operating under let's say you're
operating a parking facility or
something else
are we including all of those figures
into the 75
of budget figure or are we just looking
at general funds so we've asked
treasury for clarity on that because
obviously the more that you include
in that budget figure the better off for
those smaller entities
but there's no clarity at this point
they just say 75 percent of budget
they don't say of what budget so
so we don't know yet because in our
most of our communities 90 of our budget
goes to education
well thank you uh representative nunes
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
brock for coming in to speak with us
today
uh uh my my question's a little bit more
granular i hope that i hope that uh i'm
on a good track with this
um it's about the essential workers
portion of what you were talking about
are the decisions about essential
workers in in these
uh appropriations is this is this
only going to be made at our top
executive level or will this be made
at the executive levels of all the
different at the state of the county of
the town
because i think there were discrepancies
in the past around the pandemic about
what the governor said was essential to
what the town said was
essential so there i know that my town
is going to ask me about this
um so thankfully in the in the
legislation um
because there's two different sections
section 602 deals with the state
section 603 deals with the local
governments
there is um the payment of essential
workers in the state section
and then there's an additional payment
of the premium pay in the
local section as well so the state
executive will make a determinant of
essential workers
the executive of the state will make a
determination of the
workers of the state in that section
local governments have the authority
their executive can determine
their essential workers as well so
thank you that cleared that up for me
thank you very much
okay representative al uh almi
followed by representative spillsbury
representative elmi
thank you on i was
on i just wanted to sorry let uh
ms brock uh know that we are uh
in in new hampshire in most
of the towns all of the towns i think
and
some of the cities on the school
district is totally
independent from the municipal
government
so does the mute does this do the school
districts
get a share of this and
if not are they supposed to somehow
uh be merged in this document
and work together to figure out
everything
my school district is incredibly
independent from
our city government you right understood
so
similar to oregon similar to texas those
isd
programs are are definitely um a
consideration here because
the isd the reason that they are
independent is because they
have their own capital projects they
have their own systematic planning
um and there's a reason that their isd
so completely understand that
that separation there um but
and i think this this might muddy the
water a little bit from
uh the chairman's question um so if if
that if it is
an independent school district uh
structure
but yet those schools um let's say they
are funded by property taxes so the
property tax that right flows to the
jurisdiction over to the operations of
the k-12 system
the city then will have to determine
the the property tax decline
um as an eligible use category c
and then make a determination of whether
or not that replenishment of that money
could then spend over into the isds
what i would say um in arpa
there is an entirely separate section i
think it's
36 billion dollars that's going to
school systems
and it's through what's called the
education stabilization fund
so it's sep so so yes schools are
schools are
a benefactor of the arpa funds
in a separate category than the 350
billion dollars
we were talking about today
oh representative spellsbury thank you
mr chairman
ms brock this has been extremely
informative i appreciate it
very much obviously we're focusing our
attention here on the 350 billion
dollars
allocated to states a lot of mystery in
the remaining
1.9 trillion so i'm focused particularly
on
my community's plans for a
water interconnect project about 4.6
million
and a broadband uh infrastructure
project
about 2.1 a million
and separately my counties considering
a major renovation of the county run
nursing home so with those three
projects in mind
water and nursing home
they all seem like they may benefit from
some portion of this
pool of funds what i'm interested in is
are you aware of other funds
outside of this 365 that would be
targeted
specifically to that kind of project or
should we expect we have to find the
funds to support those
from this pool only well thinking about
those three projects
in particular um the two the first two
the broadband
and the water program seemed to fall
squarely in lgbt's category d
of the uh of these funds um
so and and then in addition um as
as as i was discussing earlier the
the nursing facility if that is a
negative economic impact of covid19 that
is there was maybe rundown of the
facility and you needed to
upkeep the facility or create hvac um
all of those things then would would
categorically be
an eligible use category a now on the
other hand
they are unique programs so broadband um
in and of itself
is um it is explicitly listed in these
proceeds and it is not explicitly listed
elsewhere in arpa
water though is a little bit different
um
there is a portion of the 1.9 trillion
dollars
that's dedicated to if they're calling
it low income water assistance program
so if there has been um a decrease in
revenues or rate paying
um revenues received in the water
facility
that possibly could be recouped in the
low-income water facility that's been
created
through arpa um so there are other
circumstances where you may want to
consider i don't know how um
how the water authority might be set up
and if it is a political subdivision of
the community or if it's run by the
community itself um
yeah that system might be eligible for
the for the rate replacement
in that lei he program i i i used an
acronym
the low income water assistance program
um
so i think there's a lot of reasons to
kind of start moving down the path of
what else is there because you sure
would like to
free up these funds to be used for other
things right
i think that's the key thing here is
that you're looking outside of that 350
billion dollars and that
that that low income water assistance
program might actually be covered
in 1.9 trillion dollars in addition what
i would say too
there is a fair amount of money for
hospitals and health care facilities
inside of the 1.9 trillion dollars it
flows through another secretariat by hhs
secretary
at um so the nursing facility may also
receive some some kind of assistance
through other parts of this program
so definitely worth thinking about um
and maybe um
what i can do is point you out point
point out those specific areas
uh for you and send that through miss
floor as well for distribution to this
committee
thank you thank you representative
thank you mr chairman and again miss
brock thank you very much for this great
presentation
my question goes back to the eligibility
usage that you talked about
as you can imagine the state of new
hampshire's uh
meals and roads tax has taken a
significant revenue hit because of the
lack of tourism
and travel in the state are you saying
that that some of that might be
recoverable
through this act yes um so
so one of the things is um obviously an
eligible use category a
they say very specifically that um these
expenditures
can be based specifically on kovid 19 or
a negative economic impact of covet 19.
for example in communities where
housing i'm sorry hospitality and
tourism
are relied on so so it could be
specifically that you are using these
funds
for those communities purposes
specifically
but then you're also kind of talking
about eligible use category c
which is that revenue replacement
category
if in those communities they had a
booked loss of revenue
based on let's say it's meal taxes or
hotel taxes
um there was a booked loss in 2020
what they're trying to say in eligible
use category c is that you
recognize that book loss and you
replenish
those revenues with these monies
and so that that is a that is um
congress trying to satisfy one of the
biggest challenges that all the
communities across the country were
saying is
we lost a lot of revenue we need to be
able to use these funds to replace those
revenues
um and we fully expect for the
communities especially
in the housing and hospitality i'm sorry
the hospitality and tourism areas
to be leaning heavily on the eligible
use category c
to recoup those revenues from the book
loss last year
great thank you very much uh
representative
thank you just a clarification of that
uh our rooms and mules tax is state
level and the communities
only gets a little of it back in revenue
sharing
on and it's not according to whether you
you need it or not in terms of tourism
or generated it on
if we have at the state level uh is this
revenue replenishment based on the the
net loss across the state budget or
is it based on on
you lost money in travel and tourism
but you gained money back in high-level
business taxes yeah i think that's that
that yes that's the question that
um we're trying to press treasury to be
very specific on
and and i use the metaphor of the zoo
so let's say um instead of the zoo let's
use it on
on yields taxes um that goes to the
state
it's it's important that new hampshire
doesn't have just one number you're not
a monolith
you have you have what's called fund
accounting
you have a booked loss over in the meals
taxes while you may not have
incurred a loss over in property tax
collection for example
we want for the treasury to allow for
that booked loss
in the meals taxes to be be
exclusively a number that you can report
back to treasury
so that you can use that to replenish
whatever else
is going on across the enterprise it's
like the zoo
or like the port those types of
facilities lost a lot of money last year
but you may not have lost money in other
categories
we want to make sure that we can
classify that look loss
specifically in its own operation to
treasury when we certify the proceeds
it's it's it's complicated but i i
you know we're we're hoping for more
clarity as quickly
as possible and
when you get this clarity uh would you
be willing to
come back to us of course i'd be
delighted
yes well thank you and i thank you we've
run out of time
because it is now 20 after 10. and we
scheduled for
an hour and we certainly thank you uh
miss brock's excellent presentation
my pleasure thank you for having me
thank you
all right now the uh for the committee
for tomorrow i had put a placeholder in
but it looks like at this point in time
we won't need to use that placeholder
tomorrow
so we will not be meeting in the morning
at nine o'clock
uh for the republicans we're going to
have a
caucus at 1 30 today
because of i told you yesterday a
different time but
because we have to jump off on this and
get into the
chair vice chair meeting that's going on
right now and so
at 1 30 we'll have a republican caucus
all right any for the question represent
all me
i think represent tucker had her hand up
first represent tucker
thank you very much yes i just would
like to know how we can
make it possible for people in our
county
to see the recording could jennifer four
send us the way that someone could link
in
to the recording of this meeting
and that's what i was going to ask jen
to uh
absolutely i'll send the youtube link um
which will be generated
after the meeting concludes so i'll
follow up um
later this morning with the link that
you can share that would be great and i
think that the people will probably also
want to be able to print the
uh slides so if you could have a
separate
way to those same people we could send
that on to them that would be great
absolutely okay put them both in one
email and we can just forward it
i will do that i would recommend that
you encourage your board of selectmen or
city councils
or county commissioners to watch this
yes i think probably some of the most
useful work we
do for them this year thank you
but now representative
thank you my question got answered so
now all i have to do is
uh remind the the democrats
on we have a caucus right after this
on if uh reps of gourd can
send out the link again to the people
that tend to lose it
uh that would be great i don't think we
should
have to take very much time for it but
we got something from
representative ames this morning
uh we did is that for a different link
that was a mistake
ignored i have mine red flagged and
everything
okay are we all set
thanks everybody i thought this morning
was very beneficial
for us and for our state and thank you
miss four
all right